I farted oh thank god thank you
appreciate that and slack the devil out
Wow
I tasted that they're nice submitted by
come to America we are an American you
[ __ ] really clever joke saying it's
funny or it could be talking about South
America cuz I read comments that people
get bothered that we call America
America cuz I mean like what about the
rest of them like dude everybody knows
when you say America is the [ __ ]
United States get off your [ __ ] high
horse [ __ ]
I understand you say North America and
the Canadians are like what about us
that makes sense cuz we talked out my
whole continent yeah Mexicans our North
American exactly that's different I
understand other than that shut the [ __ ]
up just kidding please don't hate on me
a dad is being sent to prison for
slapping his daughter after allegedly
tried to perform an exorcism on her he's
trying to slap the devil out of me go to
jail go to jail for that huh the mom
sent them off did you
lady slap her so hard that she broke her
neck and [ __ ] yeah well she lost some
teeth yeah how hard did he slap her I
tried to slap the devil out that [ __ ]
Marielle slashed me all the time and
I've never called the cops on her once
well I mean if she slapped you all the
[ __ ] time dude so annoying like how
hard does she sought there she goes like
Oh David or she's like David like it
this is my chest
like this is my chest she hits hard so
for example like remember I told you I
don't she doesn't like it when I touch
your hair but I like touching your hair
so like every now and then I just you
know whatever would not do this and this
you stop that's not self-defense
specially when blood comes out my mouth
you know she doesn't like I mean you
touch her hair do what happens I do this
she's been chasing a star am i cool you
got me baby
[Music]
this [ __ ] red but she gets super hard
when she play fights and [ __ ] she
doesn't get it like her thing is like
but you're a boy and so she'll like like
say we're in bed right I'm like ah like
that right this she'll [ __ ] like spin
her whole body runner go home boom yeah
sometimes she does it in my mind I'm
like dude [ __ ] your ass up yeah you know
let's play funny even though I'm a guy
and I'm bigger than you it doesn't
change the fact that the heel is in my
chest every time I've seen Muriel she's
always wearing a hat so when you said
that I just pictured her where your
[ __ ] tennis hat just spinning around
in [ __ ] yes that's what she does
usually yeah she'll stop she's be so oh
I'm getting angry right now cuz I can't
put her in the face
it's so [ __ ] funny how you relax
David okay if anyone out there needs to
know is how you calm down all right so
this man he's from Michigan meat chicken
his name is William it's also a name of
a dick yes Oh Willie the baby's gonna
come out so long and right now they
source a ton of rubble but there's
nothing here cuz they're behind this
[ __ ] shop dude she just [ __ ] punch
her baby's cute ass kid oh you know what
his face look like so that Willie dude
so apparently earlier in that day the 18
year old daughter saying that Willie and
other family members approached her and
apparently they've smeared some plaster
on her face that they were using earlier
to fix the home
and that they were just putting their
hands over her and saying the power of
Christ compels you
Oh oh my god is is that with usual steak
I've had that [ __ ] done to me so many
times because I had a violent tendency
when I was a kid and then other [ __ ]
parents are telling my parents that
there's [ __ ] Satan inside me it was
because the state was in me they told me
the same thing I know I just went
through it you're supposed to hold a
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] blood
it's not the same thing if you go like
this so sorry anyway so that happened
right and then she went over to the
kitchen and she was eating food that she
had bought earlier and then apparently
that's when Willie came over her dad and
confronted her about her eating his food
when she was like no this is my food and
then I guess it was so weird yeah you're
possessed you're eating daddy's food and
then that's when he ended up slapping
her let me slap that devil at your
[ __ ] face he also grabbed her by her
cheeks or by the cheeks we're talking
back to him it must be the devil in your
[ __ ] mouth yeah she called up a
friend and had how old is this girl 18
and then had her friend pick her up and
then that's when she alerted the
authorities and so now like he's in
court and he Willy is saying that he
stand his ground and that he's innocent
judge check this out she's possessed I
was just slapping the [ __ ] Satan out
of her no oh okay that's totally fine
100% agree with the father though what
she claims that this is all made up by
her but she did it oh she's eating her
own food but why does she call the cops
on the dad because apparently this dude
has been a really abusive with his
family oh why he's being sentenced to go
to prison because the judge is saying
like like you you been beating your
family yeah this is what the judge said
quote you beat up your family when are
you going to learn you can't put your
hands on your adult children you don't
get to kick her on your kids because
they're your kids
you don't get to grab her neck and slap
her in the face and so now he's facing
one to ten years in prison but that
really depends on the food that she
stole
I know he's like this is Willie you know
what people don't understand yes a cool
look it's like one of those ghost
stories like one person sees the ghost
but nobody believes them and then they
send him to the crazy home right
his whole family's possessed he's the
only one that could exercise the [ __ ]
out of them but no one believes him is
to sandwich stealing ghosts I'm telling
you my daughter took my sandwich I'm I
have to slap her do it he would make a
good model that food looks like he would
try to slap the Christ into you though
really creepy like he would think he has
this rugged look you could put a couple
tattoos on him and he's already wet
combs his hair yeah I think so it looks
like there's rage in his eyes yeah
that's the best [ __ ] me look and there
smizing looks like violent rape to me he
was probably attractive you know what I
will say this though in white people's
families there's something that I've
never ever ever ever ever seen in Asian
people families this is very specific to
food I've never seen an Asian parent
look at their kids saying hey that was
my food why did you eat that but I did
see that right - they never did that
like if you're my dad had a sandwich he
was eating and I ate a sandwich he goes
yeah of course like you it's more
important than my kitties than whatever
I have so but I always saw it like an
American families where a site who to
[ __ ] ate my fries it's like you know
that was my fries right or some [ __ ]
like that does more of a sense of
individualism yeah versus Asian not a
respect you would ask like Oh whose is
this just because you're about to crab
it but and then like my parents when I
was like oh it's yours - yeah yeah not
even me I would just eat it and then my
dad would just expect me to eat it you
know I mean I think Mexicans are like in
the middle of between Asian and white
families because I don't know a lot of
Asian families like if I need a tool I
just go grab it
but a lot of the white friends like oh
that's we need to have let's go get in
the wok I asked my dad comes home first
I'm like wait aren't your dad's tools
also your tools I know I have my I have
my hammer but if I want to borrow my
dad's hand that's his oh [ __ ] that's
crazy because in an Asian family it's
like the whole family runs off the same
[ __ ] yeah but then I think when I see
how you interact with your family if
there's a little bit of us and there's a
little bit of them
why was the
cool thing is a little bit different
because that's that's how my dad made a
living so that's different that specific
specific year that be like if your dad
was a dentist and I'm just grabbing that
little mouth I don't know what else does
it happen what do you mean no I'm not
talking about that specific tool and
that's the overall feel where you
respected Asians you don't really
respect each other's space that way but
you do it
oh that's my mom's thing my dad's being
a little bit so I give a heads up yeah
if I if I give my mom a heads up I can
do this yeah for me I can just I can go
straight to my mom's house and grab
another [ __ ] I want right now yeah and
like also to like they would be like oh
you that's my parents room don't go in
there my mom be like that matter if I go
there's no such thing as personal space
yeah or there is but it's very limited
well I actually like that I was raised
right in the middle of personal space
but still not like this is my [ __ ] you
can't be here if I might it's not like
that extreme but that's why my family my
situation with my parents is so awesome
you know what the personal space is what
my mom thinks it was knocking as she's
opening the door just trying to be
American that way
yeah so that she met in the middle yeah
we couldn't lock our doors well we
didn't I didn't lock the door I mean I'm
just having my door closed you know like
and then like instead of just opening it
like mom can you can you at least like
knock and then ask because you know I
might I had a bathroom inside my room so
I was like what if I just took a shower
you saw me naked Sheils I already seen
you naked before and I'm like I know but
like it just surprises make a I'm what
if I'm jacking off mom
exactly but like okay so then she
started going hey she's opening the door
at the same time knock knock knock
knocking hey guys would you think of
that video I know you loved it so make
sure to hit that like button to watch
more videos check it out up here
[Music]
[Music]